I am sick and tired of these efforts to
privatize a precious thing we need
public education I know we're not
supposed to be saying hate our teachers
taught us not to I hate the privatizes I
want to stop them
speaking recently before the country's
largest Union New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio came out against the very
concept of charter schools too many
Republicans but also too many Democrats
have been cozy with the charter schools
let's be blunt about it de Blasio's
opinion is a fourth tier Democratic
presidential candidate doesn't matter
much but what's disturbing is the extent
to which his anti charter animus is
rapidly becoming a core value in the
Democratic Party as the head of the
nation's largest school system de
Blasio's prejudices are also having a
direct impact on individual lives in New
York City 123 thousand students out of a
public school system of 1.1 million
attended charter schools unsurprisingly
the mayor's remarks drew hot fire from
the hometown tabloids his anger isn't
aimed at the man in the mirror who spent
eight hundred million dollars in
taxpayer money promising and miserably
failing to deliver fast and intense and
improvements in struggling traditional
public schools snarled the New York
Daily News and let the record show that
a man wealthy enough to afford to buy a
home in Park Slope who was therefore
able to send his son and daughter to
find public elementary and middle
schools and then off to selective public
high schools now wants to deny
alternatives to poorer families the
hostility that New York progressives
especially white New York progressives
have toward charters is already taking
its toll on poor minority kids stuck in
failing districts the state legislature
last month elected not to lift the cap
on the number of charters allowed in New
York City despite overwhelming demand
from parents as local political
personality and columnist Errol Lewis
noted in the 2017-18 school year about
59% of black students attending charters
passed the state math test compared with
only 25 percent in regular district
schools one charter school in the Bronx
recently saw every single one of its
eighth graders earned a perfect score on
the state algebra exam
despite being situated in the nation's
poorest congressional district half of
kids attending traditional public
schools in the same disc
failed the test 53% of the Chartres kids
are african-american 38% are Latino
81% are low-income free and reduced
lunch and there outscoring the
traditional public schools in every
measurable dimension we know I mean I
understand where there are problems like
you know there are 53,000 people on this
waiting list and and so forth but
there's nothing you can learn from them
we again I say we partner with the ones
that share those values of inclusion we
work with them best practices or share
both ways I think there are some charter
schools to do their work I think there's
some charter schools that are test prep
factories I think there's some charter
schools that are exclusionary and that
goes against everything I believe in
former congressman beta O'Rourke who
used to be a full-throated supporter of
charters was the only one of the ten
candidates at the same teachers union
conference brave enough to suggest even
that there is a place for public
nonprofit charter schools but bado
quickly got to the but but private
charter schools and voucher programs not
a single dime and my administration will
go to them what used to be a fairly
mainstream democratic idea championed by
the likes of Barack Obama Joe Biden and
pre presidential campaigns senator Cory
Booker has now become something
candidates feel like they need to
furiously backpedal from and according
to one recent survey those reformist
tendencies are not likely to be seen
again from a Democrat anytime soon Bill
de Blasio's political career has been
marked by the extent to which he's
willing to sell out his constituents in
this case poor kids in failing schools
in order to advance his own political
career sadly that puts him in the
mainstream of the modern Democratic
Party
you
[Music]